now more than eight million tons of
plastic enters the oceans every year so
Sky News is asking you to become an
ocean hero and ditch single-use plastics
well as part of the sky Ocean Rescue
campaign I've spent the last two weeks
trying to do a plastic free challenge to
try and save the world's seas and I
think it's very easy for us to forget
that the waste that we create is
actually often ending up in the oceans
which is going all over the world and I
helped to launch the ocean rescue
campaign in Mumbai saw for myself
firsthand the impact of plastics on on
the ecosystems there and that's really
been my inspiration and motivation over
the last two weeks let's take a look at
how my family and I got on the biggest
challenge really has been supermarket
shopping hasn't it and trying to get
away from the plastic yeah I guess
that's one of the the benefits it's
forced us to come to the market and you
know buy fresh produce right what do you
fancy and could we have the white
sourdough please and look not a bit of
plastic inside we have some corsets yes
nope no bags thank you so many yummy
things that looks absolutely gorgeous
can't help but notice there's absolutely
no plastic anywhere I know part of being
a farmers market stall is that we well
try and be as biodegradable as possible
I think I've got a perfectly perfect
thank you very much so I mean little
things like everyday I would start my
day during the challenge open the front
door the newspapers on the doorstep
wrapped in single-use plastic and I
would just think I've already failed at
work we have the plastic cups which I
mentioned we don't use as the water is
and more we have a tap instead
however there's plastic cups as you get
everywhere that single-use time I spoke
to the office manager and asked him if
they could replace it with paper cups
and they said yes so instantly that's an
office of 250 people no longer using
plastic cups our biggest change easily
has got to be the switch from disposable
to be to reusable nappies we've easily
cut down our use by half I mean we're
still using them but not all the time if
you're a smoker there's there's pictures
of what cigarettes Duty on on the cover
people don't see pictures of fish you
know dying and seagulls dying and all
these things Li's what will this
wildlife that's dying because of our
waste I think we have significantly
reduced the amount of plastic that we've
got through over the last two weeks in
fact the Box looks a lot less full than
last time we're not going to save the
planet
you know you're on our own overnight but
if we can effect 20 people Oh what about
the onion tart that looks good you know
who then go on to affect another 20
people then suddenly it can make a big
change you know what I think little
William might have a future in husband
not that's extremely no he's a baby
that's how to do this thank you how did
you get on because it is berry it's
quite tough isn't it give it give it
give us some tips so it's tough but it's
not as hard as you would think and I
really want to try and inspire people
and give them at some ideas of how we
got round it for example we would take a
Tupperware to the supermarkets because
you can buy a lot of meat and cheeses
and dairy products over the counter you
don't have to buy them wrapped in
plastic you can get your fruit loose
either from your local green grocers or
a farmers market or indeed from the
supermarket sometimes wrapped in
degradable product like a cardboard when
I take off my makeup which lot of women
can relate to and including studio men
instead of using a face wipe I would use
a good old-fashioned cotton pad and
makeup remover that's biodegradability
yeah that's fine oh you can't flush it
down the little hand to go in the bin
actually funnily enough it's not because
of plastics and fire degradable bin
liners really original name so James
favorite no excuses it's easy to do and
the biggest change for any parents out
there and I know a lot of people were
bulk at the suggestion and that was the
use of reuse
nappies and I just want to say before we
finish this segment it was not as bad as
you would think and in fact also some
images to my mind know you know you can
actually just reduce the amount that you
use by half and try and use them just a
wet nappies for example rather than
really dirty nappies and and that means
that you're changing 8,000,000 nappies
going to landfill every single day she
cheaper to use those isn't it much
cheaper and actually a little bit more
luxurious so please see your lovely
compared to plastic
well them I felt very useful tips thank
you for that and you can make a
difference as well by joining our
campaign we'd love you to sign up sky
ocean rescue comm is a place to go share
your stories with us on Twitter as well
at sky ocean rescue using the hashtag
Ocean Rescue and see if you can give up
single-use plastics just like as well
has done from your life and become an
ocean here it's not as hard as you might
think